the only thing I can control is me
instead of worrying about who else is
causing you problems worry about what
you can do to yourself to improve your
station and if you go down that path
you're gonna find you have a lot more
control than you think you do so here we
are on the Sunday special with Jocko
willing who's the host of The Jackal
podcast and the author of this fine book
the dichotomy of leadership which is
soon to be on the New York Times
bestseller list I'm sure we'll get to
everything involving leadership and the
military and all that kind of good stuff
but first let's talk about your job
recruitment so there are job sites that
send you tons of the wrong resumes to
sort through and that is not smart but
you know what is smart going to zip
recruiters comm slash bet and guess to
hire the right person
zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them for
you if powerful matching technology
scanning thousands of resumes
identifying people with the right skills
education and experience for your job
and actively inviting them to apply to
get qualified candidates fast and that's
why zip recruiter is rated number one by
employers in the United States that
rating comes from hiring sites on trust
pilot with over a thousand reviews right
now my listeners can try zip recruiter
for free at this exclusive web address
zip recruiter comm slash been guest
because I have a guest that zip
recruiter comm slash been guests zip
recruiter comm slash been guest and
obviously when we have to hire here when
we have to get rid of some of our
producers for just falling asleep on the
job and being terrible at their jobs
they all know they're on notice dip
recruiters comm slash been guest is the
way that we actually replace them so
sorry sorry for the notice guys but
that's how it works appropriate are the
smartest way to hire zip recruiters comm
slash been guests but Jacquelyn thanks
so much for stopping by I really
appreciate it thanks from your own so
for folks who don't know what you do you
are a leadership guru your leadership
guru in the area of business and in the
area of just general leadership and all
that started with your military
background so can you kind of get me the
story from it how you went from a kid to
a guy who's speaking for large sums of
money before leadership groups well
first of all guru is a strong word so
let's put that one in check right out of
the gate yeah I was raised in a small
New England town grew up on a dirt road
both my parents were school teachers and
I was a pretty rebellious young kid and
one of the rebellious
things that caught my eye pretty early
on was joining the military because
where I was from not too many people
join the military and then when you're
gonna go and join the military because
you want to rebel you might as well just
go and do something even more extreme
than just joining the military and I
figured out what the SEAL Teams were
when I was a young kid and I like I said
I was wanting to be some kind of
commando and so when I got out of high
school I enlisted in the Navy I ended up
at SEAL team 1 went through went through
the SEAL team training and then and then
ended up a SEAL team one and that was
before the first Gulf War I actually I
actually missed the first Gulf War
because I was going through the SEAL
training and got to a SEAL team and once
I was there I did what seals do which is
train all the time eventually he got
picked up for a Leadership Program
became a seal officer and then did
deployments until September 11th one
September 11th came then I started doing
the wartime deployments I deployed twice
to Iraq once as a seal platoon commander
one says what's called a seal task unit
commander which means there's two seal
platoons working together and I was in
charge of both of them and when I got
done with that deployment that was a
very arduous deployment we were in the
Battle of Ramadi in 2006 it was very
hard fighting the Marines and soldiers
that we worked alongside too heavy
losses but did an incredible job
we took casualties and our task unit it
was very hard fighting and when I came
home from that deployment I got asked
basically well okay Jaco what do you
want to do now and I ended up taking
over the training for the West Coast
SEAL Teams and this is the training
where you see people on TV going through
SEAL training where you carry the boats
around or you do a bunch of push-ups
this isn't that training that's our
basic training the training that I ran
was the training where you learn to
shoot move and communicate as a seal
platoon and where we actually taught
combat leadership and so I took over
that training I ran that for the last
few years and when I was getting ready
to retire a guy that I knew was a friend
of mine he was the CEO of a company and
he said hey can you come and talk to my
executives you know about about combat
leadership and I said you know sure I'll
do it he's friend of mine so I went and
did it and I don't know what he thought
I was going to talk about
but when I got done he came up to me and
said I want you to do this for every
division that I have in my company and I
said well I'm retiring and I don't know
and he said I'll give you money and I
and I said how much and we worked it out
and ended up talking to every division
that he had in his company and at one of
those divisional meetings the CEO of the
parent company was there and when I got
done you know briefing about leadership
that CEO came up to me and said hey I
want you to talk to the CEOs of all my
companies and you know he owned 45 or 50
companies and from there I went and
talked to those CEOs and the next thing
you know I I had a I had a new job you
know and I didn't get to retire like I
had planned and as I was doing that I
needed some backup and one of the guys
that work for me in the battle Ramadi a
guy by the name of leif Bab Bab and he
was one of the platoon commanders
underneath me in those two SEAL platoons
and he was getting out of the Navy and I
talked to him and said hey man I need
some backup over here and so we joined
forces and we formed this company
echelon front and that's what we do
leadership consulting and along the way
as we would talk to these companies we'd
get done talking and they'd say oh do
you have this stuff written down
anywhere do you have any you know
pamphlets you can give us so the guys
that missed the meeting can can see what
you talked about and so eventually we
looked at each other and said okay we
need to write this stuff down in a more
formal way we did that that became a
manuscript that manuscript became a book
and that book was the first book we
released it was called extreme ownership
and it ended up I kind of thought I'd be
giving it away at the back of the of you
know I speak to people and give it away
in the back and it ended up doing really
well and getting a lot of traction and
and just it's it's been it's been well
read so how much your leadership do you
think is just natural to you because
you're talking about it what I'm hearing
is obviously a guy who has tremendous
initiative from a very young age I mean
to even be from a place where nobody
goes in the military and just join the
military takes a lot of chutzpah as as
my folks would say so what do you think
that it really is that leadership is is
borders at bread yeah I get asked this
question all the time and so it's both
it's absolutely both and you as a human
being are gonna get certain
characteristics that are gonna make you
a good leader and you're gonna lack some
characteristics that would make you a
good leader if you had
you don't get tens across the board you
know it's like the little video games
you see kids play where you get a 9 in
strength and a 7 in intellect and a and
an 8 in dexterity and you get those two
as a leader and you don't get all tense
so some leadership characteristics that
make you a good leader for instance
obviously it's good to be articulate if
you can express your message clearly to
people that's gonna that's gonna help
you from a leadership perspective if you
have some natural charisma that's gonna
help you from a leadership perspective
if you can look at complex problems and
you can simplify them that's gonna be
helpful as a leader because that's what
you're doing so if you're persuasive
there's all kinds of things that will
help you as a leader and you're not
going to be good at all and so as a
leader if you look at the ones that
you're weak at you can improve them
that's that's what's beneficial so you
can't take someone that's just a
horrible leader and make them into an
amazing leader but you can take someone
that's a decent leader you can make them
into a very good or even an exceptional
leader because how you know you can
definitely get more articulate you can
definitely get more comfortable speaking
to people you can definitely get more
more precise at taking very complex
problems and simplifying them so that
your team can understand what it is that
needs to get done so these are all
things that you can improve upon and I
always have to close this out by saying
that there are some people that cannot
become better leaders and the people
that cannot become better leaders are
the people that can put their ego in
check but they lack humility and those
people they think they're doing
everything great so they're not going to
improve his leaders you can't coach him
you can't convince them they think
they're perfect and they're gonna stay
where they are from a leadership
perspective so what did you actually
learn from the first time you went
through SEAL training because you joined
the military and you decide to go to the
hardest but what everybody widely across
America knows the hardest training
program America what is that like the
the myth about SEAL training that part
of SEAL training is that you learn
anything at all because you actually
don't it's it's I mean you okay you
learn some things but it's a screening
process what they're trying to do is get
rid of people that don't want to really
really really do that job so it's it's
suffering you're gonna be doing you're
gonna be wet you're gonna be cold you're
gonna be tired and you're gonna be that
for extended periods of time and there's
an 80% attrition
but when you make it through you've you
get to a SEAL team and when you get to a
SEAL team that's when you start to
actually learn about being a seal that's
when you learn the tactics and the
leadership perspective that's when
that's when you start to become an
actual seal getting through the basic
seal training it you know when you show
up at a SEAL team everyone looks at you
you come out of there thinking you like
you just said oh I just went through the
toughest training in the world you get
to the SEAL team I literally checked in
with a Master Chief and he said everyone
here has been through that training no
one cares it's so it's very humbling
when you show up and that's when you
start to learn you start to learn when
you get into steel platoon and when it
comes to getting into the seal platoon
how do you determine leadership
positions even among people who you're
initially equals with did you think that
sort of naturally falls out or there's a
rank structure inside the military
there's a rank structure inside the SEAL
Teams and you're gonna be where you for
you and you're a new guy you're gonna be
the junior guy and then the next platoon
you're gonna be a little bit more seen
you'll have a couple guys working for
you
the platoon chief is gonna be you know
the senior guy enlisted guy in inside of
a sealed platoon and then you'll have an
officer in charge the whole thing and
those are pre designated those are pre
designated which was very countered to
my initial thought when when I joined
the Navy my dad told me I was gonna hate
it because I said why do you think I'm
gonna hate it he does cuz you don't like
to listen to anybody you don't like
Authority
and of course I told him no dad it's
just it's a team we don't have to we
don't listen to anybody it's a team and
I was completely wrong because there is
a rank structure and you absolutely you
know there's a it's the military even
though it's a team and you definitely
have you build relationships throughout
that chain of command and that is more
prominent than in some other groups but
you still there's a chain of command and
you're gonna you're gonna follow that
chain of command and there's been a lot
of talk about the possibility of
mandatory national service as somebody
who's gone through this program and I've
seen so many guys who are military some
of whom I knew you know back when they
were in high school and we're kind of
you know I can't say the words out there
but they were kind of F ups and and then
they come out the other end and they're
you know solid citizens not only solid
citizens but really making something of
themselves what do you think of the idea
of a mandatory national service I love
the idea of it
but at the same time as an American I
don't like the idea of mandating that
people do something that they don't want
to do
and and I think the volunteer military
that we have right now is it's it might
be the best in the history of world we
have a great military and I think to
mandate it I think it's problematic that
being said every single person that I
talked to especially kids that are the
age of you know 13 14 15 if you get the
opportunity to join the military then I
would definitely recommend it because
like you said it teaches you a lot of
things when it comes to you know the
application of leadership principles how
much of what you learned in leadership
training at the seals was applicable and
how much of it was you're just in a
situation and now you got it you got to
move you got to figure something out how
much of it is seat of your pants kind of
stuff well when I came in we really
didn't and it's a shocking we really
didn't have a process of leadership
training that the leaders went through
and we would basically the leaders would
learn OJT on-the-job training you'd
watch the person that was leading you
and then what is your time to take over
you'd kind of emulate what they were
doing and if you had a great leader that
worked okay if you had a bad leader that
was a real problem and so when I came
back from that deployment to Ramadi
that's one of the things I focused on is
I realized that we really needed to
implement leadership training for the
guys because you're on the battlefield
leadership is the most important thing
on the battlefield and if you don't know
what you're doing you're gonna get
people killed without question and what
would sort of they can you give me a
couple of stories to sort of demonstrate
that pointment what's what's a high
points of leadership that you've seen on
the battlefields as opposed to a low
point that you've seen in terms of
leadership well one thing that's
important to clarify yours when I talk
about leadership I'm not just talking
about me because I was in charge of the
task unit or the platoon commander
Casey's in charge the platoon or even
the people above me I'm talking about
every level of leadership every person
taking ownership of their piece of the
mission and executing executing with
authority and executing with with real
like passion about what they're doing
and so you gotta have leadership at
every level and when you don't have that
it's very problematic so what was great
for me when I came back and I took over
the training for the West Coast SEAL
Teams I got to see we put on the most
realistic combat training extremely
stressful very realistic and I would get
to see a platoon go through this
training and then the next night it'd be
another platoon going through the same
scenarios and the next night be another
platoon going through the same scenarios
so I got it was it was Bey
the most incredible leadership
laboratory it might be the most
incredible leadership laboratory that's
ever existed it was that awesome to be
able to to be able to put these these
platoons through this iterative training
and that was where it became very clear
that leadership if you had a good leader
in a sealed platoon that seal platoon
would do a good job and by the way that
leader didn't need to be the senior guy
it could have been a guy that was two or
three rungs down but when things started
happening he would step up and and take
command and make things happen
and the as long as the other leaders
maybe that were senior to them had the
wherewithal to say you know what this
guy seems to have a grip on the
situation I'm gonna let him run with it
then it'd be okay
occasion you get an egotistical leader
that would feel like oh you're stepping
on my toes and they try and put him down
and and that would be problematic but
you'd see a good solid leader anywhere
in that seal platoon would make those
seal platoons perform great and if you
had a bad leader in a sealed platoon
you'd watch the whole platoon follow
power apart if no one stepped up and
took charge and made things happen this
was very evident and that's another
thing that just solidified the
principles that we it's the same the
same principles that we teach the
businesses are literally the exact same
principles that we wrote about in
extreme ownership are the same
principles that we taught to the young
seal leaders coming up well I'm gonna
ask in a second what are some of those
leadership principles and we'll actually
get into the sort of nitty gritty from
the 30,000 foot level but first let's
talk about your impending death so life
insurance very important but one third
of people don't have it and that's
because it's kind of hard to buy you
have to work out what you need and then
do the research to find the best quote
and hopefully you don't get swindled
along the way it's not really a good way
to shop for anything so policy genius
has made the whole process a lot simpler
policy genius compares quotes from the
top life insurance companies to find the
best policy for you it takes just two
minutes to get a quote and if you don't
know the first thing about insurance
they've got all the tools to get you up
to speed
learn the difference between term and
whole life insurance calculate how much
coverage you need and be sure you're
making the right decision
in fact over four million people have
used policy genius to shop for insurance
how prevalent how good is it I can tell
you I had a listener who came up to me
he's in the life insurance industry he
said I want you to stop reading ads for
policy genius because they're putting us
out of business that's how good they are
at this policy genius doesn't just make
life insurance easy they also compared
disability insurance home insurance auto
insurance if you care about it they can
cover it so whether you know a lot about
life insurance or nothing at all
start your search of policy genius comm
cuz you're gonna plotz and when you do
you wanna make sure that your family's
taken care of in just two minutes you
can compare quotes make an informed
decision for you and your loved ones
policy genius is the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance go check it out
right now at policy genius com okay so
now jackal let's get down to some of the
main lessons of leadership so what's the
number one thing you look for in a
leader well the first book was called
extreme ownership and what that means is
you're not gonna make any excuses you're
not gonna blame anyone else you're gonna
take ownership of whatever happens and
when something goes wrong instead of
pointing fingers and blaming someone
else you're gonna take ownership of that
problem
you're gonna take ownership of figuring
it all out the solution to that problem
is and you're gonna take ownership of
implementing that solution so that is
the number one thing that I'm looking
for for a leader to do is to take
ownership of the problems and again we
call that extreme ownership and it was
one of those things that was very easy
to see in a seal platoon because when
someone doesn't take ownership and
starts pointing fingers and blaming well
like for instance right now if I started
putting my finger and blaming you for
something what's your natural reaction
gonna you get defensive get upset I mean
it's not my fault this broadcast isn't
what I wanted it to be exactly exactly
and then what happens is we have a team
where you're pointing that I'm pointing
the finger you you're putting the finger
to someone else and now we have no one
taking ownership of the problems and
therefore the problems never get solved
the opposite of that is when you have a
good leader that steps up and says hey
Ben you know what this broadcast didn't
go the way I wanted it to I should have
done a better job preparing - for your
questions I'm sorry I apologize and now
instead of you getting defense if you
say you know what no actually I could
have done a better job and now both of
us are taking ownership of the problems
and we're gonna get them solved so
that's kind of the number one
characteristic is someone has the
humility because it hurts it stings when
something goes wrong and you're a leader
and you say oh you know what all this
was bad situation it's my fault I'll
take ownership of it that hurts that
stings the ego so you have to be humble
in order to do that how much of
leadership is it sounds like a lot of it
is just being good person
interpersonally because it sounds like
you can take that same message and apply
it to marriage where it's not really a
question of you leading your spouse but
if you start blaming your spouse the the
the whole thing falls apart nearly
immediately whereas if you have no
expectations of your spouse and it's
just you're gonna take responsibility
for whatever happens then your marriage
goes a lot better yeah no doubt about it
and we definitely as soon as the first
book came out we got all kinds of
feedback from
people in every type of scenario that
when they started taking ownership of
their relationship with their wives with
their spouses that it gets better and
obviously this translates to personal
responsibility because when you're
walking around and you're saying oh it's
my family and it's it's it's the market
or it's the it's the way I was raised
and these are the things that are
holding me back and all you're doing is
blaming everyone else it you don't take
ownership of those problems and that's
gonna be problematic the best thing to
say is okay look whatever happened
happened I'm gonna take control of what
I can I'm gonna go forth and conquer so
the regard of the future of the country
I mean obviously my mind jumps
politically and I think that we're
living in an era where there's a lot of
political capital be gained by
politicians particularly in telling
people that they are victims and that
their first move ought to be to blame
the system or blame factors outside
their control seems like you're arguing
exactly the opposite if you want to have
a happy life and maybe you first start
to start taking responsibility for the
decisions that are within your purview
if you were if you were speaking people
politically what would you be telling
people along these lines yeah that's a
hundred percent right I mean if you if
you're blaming everyone else I can't
control you I can't control these other
things outside I can't I can't control
the only thing I can control is me so
instead of worrying about who else is
causing you problems worry about what
you can do to yourself to improve your
station and if you go down that path
you're gonna find you have a lot more
control than you think you do
so how do you deal about with situations
in which it really is the person's fault
right so you're taking responsibility
for everything but at the same time you
just have somebody who's screwed up in a
serious way I just read an editorial or
an op-ed in the in the Wall Street
Journal about a guy who was chewed out
at one point by Steve Jobs he's working
at Apple and Steve Jobs approaches him
obviously the corn corn ultimate leader
in the tech sector and he just looked at
what the guy was doing he said this is
garbage and then he just walked away and
the guy said well you know it made me
feel bad at the time but I realized that
sometimes it encouraged me to do better
well what do you think of that sort of
leadership style are there times where
you just have to choose somebody out and
is that ever useful there are very few
occasions because I'll tell you from a
leadership perspective if you're working
for me and you screw something up whose
fault is up I mean presumably it's it's
your fault for hiring me
not number one why did I hire you if you
can't do the job but even if let's say I
did hire you did I give you the right
guidance did I give you the right
support did I actually check back in
with you and make sure that you had the
resources that you needed to get the
thing done did I make sure that you were
trained properly and there's all these
things that I look back at myself and
say if my subordinates now if my
subordinates aren't doing what I need
them to do that is my fault now to your
question do you occasionally get someone
that is either incapable of doing the
job for whatever reason they don't have
the cognitive capacity or they don't
have the physical capacity or they don't
have the the right attitude to get a job
done does that happen sometimes yes it
absolutely does you know we talked about
that in the new book we had got might
might after it's called task unit
bruiser and we had two guys inside of
task unit bruiser that when we went
through our pre deployment training they
they didn't cut it and you know look we
did everything we could to mentor to
train them to get them up to speed but
ultimately you get to a point as a
leader where you recognize this person
is is they're just not capable of doing
the job and I'm putting all my resources
into this one individual and I'm now
starting to show them the rest of the
team because I'm focused on one person
so I'm actually hurting the rest of the
team so even though I have loyalty and I
take ownership of the of the
subordinates that are working for me at
some point my loyalty to the team will
trump my loyalty to one individual and I
have to make a hard decision to get rid
of that person it's gonna be bizarre
question but my mind is going toward
family situations what do you do with
kids like let's say that you have you
got several kids I had four kids and
let's say them one of them is a slacker
and it's not a situation we can just
sort of cut them in and fire them a kid
stuck with it you know you got to do it
you got to do how do you how do you
determine where to put your resources
given that one kid very often is it
requires more attention than another kid
in this sort of area the the the thing
with raising kids is and again I used to
shy away from talking about this because
I used to say you know what my kids with
the results aren't in yet and also it's
like what you know Pheo is your kids
successful what does that actually mean
because my kid could go and make a ton a
ton of money but have a horrible family
life and and be frightened be a jerk
right is that is that success no or they
could be very happy but have no money
and we live in day to day and so that
that's not successful either but my kids
are a little bit older now and I can see
this trajectory that they are on and
and quite frankly I'm pretty happy with
the way my kids have turned out it's
it's it's it's a hard thing to look at
because you can't fully control it and
so what are you gonna do with your kids
you know I like to you've got to give
them guidance right but you also have to
let them brush up against the guardrails
of failure you know a simple example
that I would say and I probably have
taken some flak for this as I say if
you're helping your kids you're hurting
your kids and what I mean by that
something as simple as tying your shoe
right if you help your kid when they're
whatever age two years old three years
old if you help them tie your shoe tie
their shoe you're actually taking away
an opportunity the opportunity for them
to develop their fine motor skills
that's really happening at that moment
so if you do that if you cook them every
meal if you don't let them you know get
their cereal bowl out and guess what
they're gonna spill milk sometimes and
they're gonna knock over the cereal and
at the same time they're developing
skills are gonna help them fend for
themselves in the world so what you have
to do is you have to let them brush up
against the guardrails of failure from
time to time now where it becomes
challenging as a parent and and thank
God I haven't faced anything like this
sometimes your kids will we'll take
turns that will ruin their life right
that will ruin their life and you know
obviously I'm not gonna let one of my
kids ruin their lives that being said if
people take a really hard turn and and
do things that are completely against
the parameters that you believe in and
you continue to support them they're
gonna continue to take advantage of you
and so I've seen that happen with
parents where kids go down the wrong
direction I can't like I said I can't
even imagine the the catch-22 that you
get in in that situation where you know
if your kid becomes a drug addict and
you want nothing more than to help them
but every time you give them the support
that you think is going to help them
you're actually just enabling them and
so again I'm no expert what I try and do
is put a put a box around the kids let
them develop let them grow and put the
guardrails out there let them know
when you when they disappoint you but
the other part of this is and this is
another hard thing for people to
understand it was definitely hard for me
to understand your kids aren't gonna be
who you want them to be they're gonna be
who they are and in my opinion the more
you force them to try and be what it is
you want them to be the harder the
pushback is going to be and you can end
up with some really horrible situations
okay so we talked about taking extreme
responsibility what are some of the
other attributes of leaders that you
look for well humility is obviously the
big one you got to be humble if you're
not humble then that's gonna be
problematic now what's interesting new
book that just came out is dichotomy
leadership and what does that mean that
means that as a leader you have to be
balanced right you have to be balanced
so let's just take humility and ego
because we're looking for people that
are humble but at the same time you can
have someone that's so humble that they
lack confidence that's bad on the other
side of that spectrum you can have
someone that's so confident that they're
overconfident their egos big and they
don't listen anyone else where do you
want to be you want to be balanced
somewhere in the middle I talked about
the fact that you need to be articulate
as a leader that's great can you be a
leader that talks so much that people
stop listening to you the other end of
the spectrum is you are a leader that
doesn't say enough and now the team
doesn't know what direction they're
supposed to be going in so where do you
want to be you want to be somewhere in
the middle you want to be balanced and
so what we've seen working with after
that book extreme ownership came out we
saw leaders the biggest problem that
leaders have because the last chapter in
extreme ownership is called the
dichotomy leadership it's talking about
this points but we didn't go deep enough
it was only one chapter and as we
continue to work with leaders hundreds
of leaders you realize the problem the
problem that they suffer the most is
they go too far in one direction or the
other so the really the best
characteristic to have them as a leader
is is to be balanced a certain amount of
that authenticity because how much can
you train into being a leader and move
yourself out of where you authentically
are so you tend to be a quiet person and
now you're trying to train yourself into
being the guy who can give a rah-rah
motivational speech on the floor are you
better off just perfecting the skills
that you already have or are you better
off working on the skills that you lack
you know it's it's interesting you talk
about this the fact of just being loud
right you said a quiet person being loud
is a characteristic of a good leader it
absolutely is and especially of being a
combat leader because if you're in a
combat situation and you need guys to
move to that door over there and there's
a machine-gun fight going on the only
way you're gonna do it is if you're loud
enough to make that happen you're loud
enough to yell and let everyone know
that I had a guy coming through my
training really smart guy Ivy League guy
very cerebral quiet as a mouse and I
said to him I said listen you're gonna
need to get loud like your guys cannot
hear you you're gonna need to learn to
project your voice he was for all
practical purposes as far as I could
tell physically incapable of projecting
his voice and so as I was watching him
go through these iterations I kept
saying to him you got to be louder
you've got to be louder your guys can't
hear you and I didn't think he was gonna
make it and then one iteration that
they're going through
I see me needs to get guys over to this
door over here and he grabs Billy who is
the biggest loudmouth in the platoon and
he goes Billy get everyone to that door
over there and Billy look well everyone
get to that door and everyone moved and
I realized that he was smarter than me
what he figured out was he could
complement an area of weakness that he
had with his team and so yes there's
ways that you can increase your
capabilities and like I said you can
become more articulate you can learn to
simplify more you can become more
persuasive if you continue to try and
talk to people but maybe something like
being loud this guy just couldn't do it
but he was able to take his team and
pull the strengths and his team together
to become a better leader himself and
that's always something that a good
leader will do here all the time
surround yourself with good people I
would add to that surround yourself with
good people that compliment the areas
that you're weak
so how do you get a leader who's let's
say an 80% leader to a 95 percent leader
is this somebody who is just lacking
motivation or is it somebody who
requires a skill set like what you have
a guy and you think he's good raw
material are there actual exercises in
which you can engage to become a better
leader oh yeah absolutely I mean when
the SEAL Teams what we would do is we
would run guys through these really
complicated training scenarios that I'm
talking about in the business world we
do role-playing with people and I'll put
you in a situation as a leader when I
say okay I'm your worst nightmare and
or not even your worst nightmare hey I'm
that I'm that older guy that's been
doing this for 25 years and I don't want
to change the way I'm doing anything and
you got to get me to change it let's go
let's figure this out and what you see
is two three four iterations of having
these hard conversations people get
better at them that's one aspect of
leadership that you can definitely get
better at we run through planning drills
so people learn to simplify we run
through communication drills so people
learn to simplify their message there's
all kinds of ways to go from that 80%
leader to the ninety five hundred
percent leader when it comes to you know
the even in situations I was in warfare
situations how much of the textbook
stuff is is applicable I mean is it just
you have to live through it and then a
certain natural leadership capacity
takes over or is it that you you can
game out all this stuff I mean is it
possible to really game out crisis
scenarios or is it basically the best
that you can and then and then you're
just doing what you do here's here's the
answer to that combat and this is very
counterintuitive for what people might
think
combat is an absolute exercise in
creativity and when you're in these
situations you have to have an open mind
you have to know the principles you have
to understand combat but then you have
to be able to take those principles and
apply them in modulate them and utilize
them in ways that they may have never
have been utilized before so that you
can get the outcome that you desire it's
a it's a very it's a very creative
focused job and people miss that a lot
and that's why the training that I ran
we really focused on forcing the leaders
to get creative to solve problems so
let's talk a little about some of the
leadership examples that we all have in
common so we we have you know the movies
provide us tons of examples of what they
see as good leaders who are some
examples of leaders that you've seen in
either everyday life or in politics as
some leaders that you seen you say
that's what a good leader looks like
because we all have this sort of picture
of a leader in our head that it's an
Abraham Lincoln figure tall person who
have only speaks when necessary or the
the leader that comes to mind for me is
the is now what's the name of the actor
in a band of brothers did the I don't
know the a name but I know that he's
trying to portray
dick winter dick winters exactly exactly
so that's that's the image that a lot of
folks have from from pop culture who
would be you know your your leaders that
you look to and you say these are the
ones who do I see is sort of the heroic
leaders yeah I mean dick winters that's
a fantastic example I've covered his
books on my podcast because he's a
leader that that does every one of these
little nuance things you can see him do
it and Band of Brothers is is an amazing
series that really shows the nuances of
his leadership so I think that's
fantastic one of the leaders that that I
always tried to emulate as a guy by the
name of colonel david hackworth who was
one of the most decorated soldiers he
served in Korea and in Vietnam and he
wrote a book called about-face which is
about an eight hundred page book and
it's it's really not about leadership at
all overtly
but it's a hundred percent about
leadership as you read it and if you're
looking for those lessons but he was a
guy that again he balanced all these
dichotomies very effectively
he was completely revered by the people
that worked for him most of the people
that he worked for loved him and loved
having having him on their team however
and this is you know part of the
dichotomy he's the guy that he's one of
the first senior leaders in Vietnam that
said look if we don't change the way
we're fighting this war we are not going
to win and they drummed him out of the
Army in a matter of months after that
because and to me it was him
speaking the truth as he saw it which I
have great respect for him so when you
look at today's politics obvious what I
do for a living
and it feels extraordinarily chaotic it
feels like it's a war of all against all
it's or this Hobbesian this Hobbesian
state of nature do you see that as a
lack of leadership or is it that there
are too many people who think their
leaders fighting with one another I
think it's a little bit of both I think
we're getting accustomed to this new
world where you can get reactions on a
minute-by-minute basis and one of the
best ways to get reactions from people
is to make statements that are extreme
and so again you know this this new book
which dichotomy leadership it's about
balance and right now I would say in
politics we we don't find very much
balance we find people on both sides
that are that are leaning towards the
extremes all the time and then that gets
greatly amplified by the media how much
of leadership involves actually having a
group of people who have the same common
goal because when one of the big
problems that I'm seeing in our politics
generally and I think this is true you
know just in a fragmented society that
focuses very much on the individual I'm
an individualist I really believe that
people should have the right to do
essentially what they want so long as
they're not harming anyone else but it
seems like the success of a team whether
it's a Navy SEAL team or any other team
relies on having the same common goal
how much of that can be instilled by
leadership and how much of that is just
you know you joined the team voluntarily
you knew what you were getting into and
can that be restored if there's if
there's a lack of goal-oriented Ness and
in the society as a whole you have to
have a some kind of common goal you
absolutely do now without a common goal
you don't know where you're going now
where we run into trouble in a team or
in in the political environment we're in
right now
is there's different ways to get to that
goal right there's different ways to get
to that goal I mean I don't think
there's anyone okay maybe there are but
generally people want want good for the
world right there's no there's no one
that's thinking hey we want a
dictatorship in America there's no one
that's no normal people are saying that
right we all have a common goal we want
to do we want to we want families to
have good lives we want people to be
taken care of we want you to have an
opportunity we want to have a good
economy right these are all things that
are pretty standard I don't think we're
gonna get fighting against that where we
get fighting is how we're gonna get
there and disagreements on how we're
gonna get there and then what we see is
we see people that put a stake in the
ground on their idea and don't want to
listen anyone else and in a team
environment
that's problematic it boils down to ego
right hey I'm not gonna listen to your
idea I want to go with my idea and you
know what there'll be no compromise
there'll be no compromise we're only
gonna do it my way and I would rather
not execute the mission not accomplished
the mission then not do it my way
and so when I see that that's that's
that's problematic how you solve it
eventually if you're gonna move forward
you have to solve it you have to find
out what those compromises are gonna be
yeah and this is where I actually wonder
whether that's true maybe it maybe I
have a more pessimistic view of the
country then you do actually at this
point because I do wonder whether we
agree on the end points and
just disagreeing about the means I think
that a lot of folks like nobody's gonna
come out and say I want a dictatorship
there a lot of folks will say I would
like to restrict X right for this group
of people because I think that right as
exercised is hurting me
I know due process rights for particular
sets of crime we need to shut down this
particular sort of speech because the
sort of speech hurts me at a certain
point I do wonder whether we lack even
the common language of goals in order to
in order to arrive at a common
destination are you pessimistic or
optimistic about the country I'm less
pessimistic than you are with that and
with those type of examples because I
don't see those as I see those as fringe
and again I don't live in the same world
as you do you know you're I mean the
worst of the edgy panel takes all days
near this constant firefight with this
stuff I in an in normal American I work
with busy all over the country and you
know what I hate to break the news to
you most people aren't watching News 24
hours a day most people aren't listening
to those fringe people on either side
most people are out there working hard
trying to make a living trying to take
care of their family that's what the I
mean it's it's beyond the vast majority
is the absolute vast majority of the
people that I work with every day are
people that want to improve their
station in life they want to help their
team win they want to do good work
they got pride in what they're doing
that's what most people I mean
construction manufacturing finance I
mean that's what these people are doing
and so the fringe people that are out
screaming and yelling they're they're
loud and the media focus is on them why
well you know it's because they the
media wants to get people to click and
hear what that crazy person has to say
most of America we don't click on that
stuff
we don't what do you think civilians
don't understand about the military that
you wish they understood more very few
Americans actually now know somebody who
serves in the military or has served in
the military used to be that a huge
percentage of Americans served now it's
like 2 percent of Americans serve in the
military what do you think that
civilians really ought to know about how
the military operates and what the
military lifestyle is like whole number
one I think the most important thing to
understand about people in the military
is that they're people is that they're
people and these are people with with
husbands and wives these are people with
kids these are people with goals
and they're people with emotions and I
think sometimes when you see a picture
of a soldier of a sailor of an Airmen of
a Marine you think of them as that thing
as a soldier as a sailor as an airman as
a marine and we often forget that that
soldier sailor Airman marine that
service member they they are a person
and they have a life and so I think
that's what happens when guys come home
and they don't have a new mission to
focus on they get a little bit lost and
people don't know how to treat them so I
say it's real a straight simple and
straightforward their people treat them
like people and give them give them the
respect that they deserve absolutely
because the sacrifices that they make
are not they're not sacrifices made by a
robot they're sacrifices made by a
person and like in my case and the
families as well you know in my case
when I was on my last deployment to
Ramadi I left my wife at home with three
young kids and I knew what I was doing I
knew what my day-to-day circumstances
were my wife didn't know my wife was at
home raising kids and by the way going
to visit my wounded guys in the hospital
going to my guys funerals that is an
incredible sacrifice on the homefront as
well so I think it's important just to
remember that these are people both the
service members and their families yeah
that's pretty amazing how did you meet
your wife I met my wife in I was
overseas and she was overseas and we met
in church pretty good place to meet
there was beer served at the bar she
sounds like a pretty amazing person so
how did she deal with with all of this
with with you being overseas in in the
middle of a battle area it was hard and
I think my wife has is is I think the
key component of my wife that made her
you know we've been married for
20-something years I always tell her
seems like forever but you know we've
been married for a long time through
multiple deployments overseas and I
think for her what makes her able to
cope with this is that she's emotionally
independent from me she doesn't need my
phone call every day to reassure her her
that everything's okay and and that you
know I'm coming back or whatever she
she's emotionally dependent and of
course she's independent and she could
hand
the broken water heater and the flat
tire and the whatever other problems the
sick kids she could handle all that
stuff so she's independent in that way
but she's emotionally independent as
well and didn't rely on me every day to
give her the boost she's confident you
know squared away woman so it sounds
like you're obviously anti-feminist I
mean that's as is a former member of the
military and seemed obviously I mean
this that's what we all assume well I've
seen I have three daughters and and then
one son and you know my daughters are
you know I wrote a couple books about
kids for kids books called warrior kid
way to warrior kid and it's about it's
about kids instead of accepting weakness
it's about kids trying to become
stronger which to me seems like a pretty
fundamental thought but if you read a
lot of kids books and you have kids you
probably see them there's not a lot of
kid books that actually tell kids that
hey what you want to do is you want to
work hard and you want to be stronger
and you want to you want to be the best
that you can be so I did that with my
kids and I wrote these kids books for
them but yeah my my daughters are
absolute warrior kids and now they're
warrior adults but so you bring a lot of
lessons from the military to the
civilian area have you learned anything
in sort of the business area that that
you think would be applicable to the
military well what have you learned in
civilian life that you think added to
what you already knew from your from
your service but the the biggest and
most shocking thing that I learned about
the civilian sector was that leadership
is leadership and and the same problems
that a company with a thousand employees
would have are literally the same
problems that a seal platoon was 16 guys
would have and learning that and I'm
beginning to understand it didn't take
me very long at all as soon as I looked
at what was sitting down with the first
CEO I ever worked with and he started
telling me the problems they were having
and I just inside I was just chuckling
saying you got to be kidding me I seen
this over and over again with a seal
platoon here's what the issue is let's
address it this way so that was the
biggest lesson learned for me his
leadership his leadership his leadership
so you're pretty intense dude you're the
only person I've ever had on this this
podcast who probably speaks as quickly
as I do so have you have you always been
like that or is that something that's
gotten you into trouble how you know was
was this something that you cultivated
you were always this intensive person
know if you listen to my podcast you'll
find that I actually talk very slowly
generally
but it depends on you know sometimes you
got to get your point across and you
know I know your audience is probably
pretty quick pace they don't want to
hear my my slow talk and again you know
on my podcast I'm I'm usually dealing
with with very heavy subjects you know I
talk about war and I talk about
atrocities and really it's a podcast
about human nature through the lens of
leadership and so the subjects are heavy
sometimes that warrants a little bit
more a little bit more nuance when I'm
talking and but yeah I guess if I'm
talking as fast as you that's a scary
thing so what do you what do you think
it is about human nature so let's talk
about that a little bit what do you what
do you see human beings as what is our
fundamental nature because this is what
all politics is about yeah again one of
most interesting things about human
nature is that all human beings are
completely different and yet all human
beings are kind of the same and one one
thing that you find is that through war
and through other and through atrocities
is you get to see human nature be
revealed and what I do at the podcast
from my perspective the better you
understand human nature the better you
can lead people because you've got to
understand where they're coming from
you got to understand how their ego is
gonna react to things you got to
understand like you said earlier when
people get defensive how do you get
around that you got to understand what
what people don't like to expose you got
to understand how they're gonna interact
with other people how they're gonna come
across when you get aggressive or not
aggressive enough so the better you
understand human nature the better
you're gonna be able to lead and one of
the things you know I was just did
assists at West Point as a matter of
fact I was talking to the soldiers to be
up there and one of the things I was
talking about was the fact that I said
listen you take a platoon an army a
Marine Corps infantry platoon or seal
platoon inside the a platoon you've got
a person in there that's a sadist
they're in there you've got some people
you've got another person that is is one
of the most wholesome good people you
could ever imagine you've got both of
them and you got every person in between
and if you don't understand that as a
leader if you don't understand what
these individuals that work for you are
capable
of then that's going to be problematic
when you're in a leadership position so
understanding human nature understanding
that there's good and there's evil
inside of everyone and and everyone's
capable of going in those direction no I
covered the meal I'm asked her on my
podcast and when I was up at West Point
I was talking and I got looks from the
crowd from some of the actual current
leaders from the crowd was kind of like
wait wait what do you mean we don't have
it we don't have a sadist we don't have
a murderer in a platoon and I said you
know think about the meal I mascar the
meal I masker was a company of normal
people and it's it's a horrific podcast
to listen to because normal kids from
all over America that you wouldn't think
in a million years would commit an
atrocity once they crossed over that
line they were committing horrible rape
mutilation and murder and what was
really interesting about this and when I
did that podcast and I tried to bring
home something good about it
what I brought home and and the way the
point that I took away was that what
happened on that massacre these guys
were in a complete melee of murder rape
mutilation it was it was awful and a
helicopter pilot came in saw was
happening went back to base and he told
the commander hey these guys are out
there committing an atrocity that
commander got on the radio said stop
killing people right now and you know
what they all stopped they all stopped
right there and that was proof that to
me is proof of the power of leadership
because it was a bad leader that took
him in a bad direction and they went off
the off completely off the rails and a
good leader stepped in and was able to
straighten them back out that's the kind
of thing that if you don't understand
you've got that element of human nature
as a leader especially in in chaotic and
combat situations but even in a business
if you don't understand those things
it's gonna be problematic for you
obviously we've seen this from civilized
armies all over the world situations
where things go wrong and suddenly
people who are innately civilized you
thought are suddenly acting uncivilized
as a leader can you spot that sort of
stuff early or you can only stop it once
it's begun I think the way you stop it
early is you have to you have to address
it early you have to explain to everyone
everyone has to understand where you
stand as a leader what where you stand
as a leader and where you stand as a
nation right we can't
do this kind of thing this will hurt our
strategic goals this will impact us in a
negative way on this particular
battlefield and most important I will
not let it happen so again I mean in the
battle Ramadi it was it was it was a
hard fight and you can see I mean I
could see you've got you when one of my
guys gets killed and his friends have to
go on a mission
a day later two days later three days
later this is awful and if you don't if
you don't understand what can take place
not saying it would take place but if
then it might and so you have to you
have to be aware of it and that's where
I think awareness and understanding of
human nature is what will prevent these
things for happening because you don't
know you don't know you know what maybe
you're a good judge of character maybe
I'm a good judge of character maybe I
get 80% right maybe I could judge hey
80% hey this guy looks like he might do
something bad and this guy looks like
he'll never would maybe I'm 80% right
the other 20% is the one that's gonna is
going to be a problem the times that
you're wrong because we don't know you
don't know what happens to people under
stress you don't know what happens when
people see their friends get wounded or
killed you know you were you were
talking early about your imminent death
right it's like a joke like hey we'll
talk about about a minute about your
imminent death when you're in combat all
of a sudden that's a real thing and
depending on your mindset your death can
be completely imminent in your mind and
so what does that do to a person's
psyche what does that allow them to do
that they may never do in a normal
circumstance as a leader you got to
understand those things what do you do
if you're not a leader what you're just
not a natural leader but you're but
you're being led by somebody who you
think is just not doing the job what
should you do there are too many
situations in certainly civilian life
where your boss an idiot what do you do
what do you do if what should you do if
your boss in in it yeah well first of
all those situations occur on the
military all the time as well the
military does not completely weed out
every bad leader no there's a bell curve
in the military just like any other any
other organization there's some great
guys at the top there's okay people in
the middle decent people in the middle
of the squared-away people in the middle
and there's some real bad leaders at the
bottom end and you don't know who you're
gonna get so this is a quest
I get asked all the time what do you do
when your leader is not good well it's a
really easy answer for me when my leader
isn't good you know what I do I lead I'm
gonna step up and lead and it depends on
the situation if I have a weak leader I
can literally step up and lead because
my leader doesn't want to make a
decision hey boss we're gonna do this is
that okay I'm not gonna step on his toes
because we got to be very careful that
I'm not stepping on my leaders toes
because we might offend their ego that
could be problematic but I'm gonna step
up and and say hey boss we want to do
this is this make sense yeah okay that
makes sense do it if I have a weak
leader I'm gonna step up and lead if I
have an egomaniacal leader that is a
crazy micromanager what I'm gonna do
again the same thing I'm gonna do with
every leader I'm gonna form a great
relationship with them I'm gonna form a
great relationship if you're
micromanaging me me I'm gonna say hey
boss I know you wanted these 12 things
reported to you well I didn't think I
was good enough here's 16 things you
wanted in the report so I want you to
really understand and know what's going
on boss here you go I'm gonna give you
more information than you could ever
possibly even hope for and eventually
you're gonna say hey okay Jacque or you
know what just go and do your thing but
you're gonna build I'm gonna build a
relationship with you I'm gonna build
trust with you whether you know and this
is another thing that shocks people I
worked for on that bell curve of great
leaders and horrible leaders I work for
all of them I work for incredible
strategic tactical masters that were
inspiring leaders and I worked for just
egomaniacal
tactically horrible leaders and everyone
in between and my relationship with all
those leaders was the same with all
those leaders I had the same
relationship they trusted me they gave
me what I needed to get the job done and
then they got out of my way and let me
do it how did I go about building those
relationships well again how calculate
you asked me to do something that's dumb
that doesn't make sense and I know I
would never do this and I think you're a
bad leader for making me do it guess
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna do it if if
it's something that's not gonna put my
men in jeopardy or the mission in
jeopardy I'm gonna do it you want me to
wear this certain thing a certain way
I'm gonna do it you want me to do the
mission a little bit different than the
way I would have done it but but that's
your guidance I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
make you trust me I'm gonna build up
trust with you so eventually when you
tell me to do something that makes no
sense whatsoever that's gonna put my men
in jeopardy or the mission in jeopardy I
can look at you and say hey you know
what Ben I see what you want to get done
how about we do it this way I think it's
gonna make a
but more sense it'll keep everyone safe
er since you and I now have a
relationship we trust each other you
trust me you go oh you know what Jocko
good call go ahead and do it that way so
these situations what am I gonna do I'm
gonna build a relationship okay so what
do you do as a going back to parenting
for a second yeah we're talking about
leadership lessons that adults can learn
how do you inculcate leadership in
children cuz you see some kids I see
with my own kids one of them happens to
be a real natural leader people tend to
follow her and the other one is he's two
and a half but he's a wild man how do
you inculcate leadership in in kids how
do you teach those lessons from the time
that they're young yeah and it's the
same the same answer for what you do
with your kids is the same answer you do
with a young seal that you want to step
up and become a better leader how do you
do it you put them in charge of things
you put them in charge of things you let
them step up and lead whether it's
something big whether it's something
small you start them off small in a
business you start them off with
something that's not going to cost a
bunch of money if they mess it up or
something you can bring back on the
rails if they go off the rails a little
bit in combat you give them a mission
that's not that dangerous or it's a
training mission and you let them run it
as a kid hey you know I mean it's
something as silly as a lemonade stand
right that's that's a real thing when
you're a kid that's a real thing when
you're a kid that's happy right that's
Google when you're running that lemonade
stands so let them step up let them take
leadership let them take some hits
maybe they lose money when you when you
charge them when you charge them the
money that it cost for the lemonade mix
and you know it cost whatever $4.99 for
the lemonade mix and you take it from
them and then they don't make that money
back on the street let them learn that
lesson let them figure out how they're
gonna make it happen so again you put
out the guardrails but most important to
try and develop leaders you put people
in leadership positions you don't let
them you don't let them die you don't
let them fall flat on their face you
don't in a business you don't let them
cost their company a giant amount of
money but you do let them brush up
against failure as a leader when is it
time to cut somebody loose first of all
the reason people feel bad usually when
they fire someone is because they know
that they didn't do a good job as a
leader mentoring coaching teaching and
then finally explaining the person
explaining to the person in no uncertain
terms here's what I expect from you and
here's what's gonna happen if you don't
do it you're gonna get fired so the way
you know
first of all you've gone through those
steps and second of all you realize that
they can't meet the expectations you've
given them fair treatment and now you
say listen you you you aren't capable of
this job and right now it's negatively
impacting the whole team and I want to
take care of you but it's more important
that I take care of the whole team so
I'm gonna write you a great resume I'm
gonna call anyone back that anyone who
wants reference use me as a reference
I'll take care of you but this this job
just isn't for you so I do want to ask
you one final question I want you to
evaluate president Trump's leadership
but if you want to hear jockle willing
to answer you have to be a daily wire
subscriber to subscribe go to daily wire
comm click Subscribe you can hear the
end of our conversation there well
jockle willing thanks so much for
stopping by check out the Jocko podcast
and go get his new book that I cotta me
of leadership it's a pleasure to have
you I really appreciate it thanks Robert
appreciate it
[Music]
Avenger Pierrot shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy Boren associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex singhara audio is
mixed by Mike Carroll Mina Heron make up
is by Jess wa-l vera and title graphics
by Cynthia and Gullu the Ben Shapiro
shows Sunday special is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018
[Music]